un divorcio siempre deja secuelas es lo
que está sucediendo con el break sheet
concretamente en irlanda del norte donde
paramilitares unionistas británicos
levantaron su apoyo a los acuerdos del
viernes santo de 1998 que pusieron fin a
una sangrienta guerra de tres décadas lo
hicieron mediante un comunicado si
vosotros el reino unido no estáis
preparados para honrar la totalidad del
acuerdo entonces seréis responsables de
la permanente destrucción del acuerdo el
acuerdo deber éxito establecía en el
protocolo de irlanda del norte que la
aduana fronteriza estará fijada en los
puertos de belfast y land de esta forma
se evita que haya una frontera física
entre irlanda y la provincia de reino
unido irlanda del norte uno de los
principales logros de los acuerdos de
paz de 1998 sin embargo el break sheet
ha revivido viejos fantasmas y la aduana
dentro del reino unido entre islas está
provocando escasez de productos y
malestar entre los sectores protestantes
y unionistas piden que se revoque por
completo al protocolo de irlanda del
norte y no tener fronteras con reino
unido sin embargo sin este protocolo la
unión europea no hubiera permitido
de forma que en la práctica irlanda del
norte continuará formando a largo plazo
parte del mercado comunitario en este
contexto el primer ministro británico
boris johnson trata de prorrogar
unilateralmente hasta octubre el período
de gracia acordado con bruselas
esto significa que reino unido está
extendiendo la entrada en vigor de los
controles aduaneros y sanitarios
definitivos
estoy seguro que con un poco de buena
voluntad y sentido común todos estos
problemas técnicos son eminentemente
solucionables bid hollywood
sin embargo la unión europea' ha
mostrado su modestia y aseguran que
reinó unido- está violando la ley
internacional ya que el acuerdo
establecía que en junio como muy tarde
debía comenzar la frontera aduanera
virtual y totalmente efectiva entre el
reino unido e irlanda del norte